qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
un élastique et l'hostis cycle je savais
pas que tu fais de la moto j'ai des fans
possibles et après le jeu sur mac tu
sais pas après deux bonnes crois moi tu
as raté
[Musique]
génial celle là est électrique
ah oui mais c'est bien un peu nerveuse
mais je vais l'attenté va être super je
vais être super et toi aussi
on va être super
[Musique]
bon
tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les a bien séché viande et légumes
c'est moi sinon est ce qu il est prévu
qu'on en parle un jour quoi du sujet
tabou évidemment quel sujet tabou le
nouveau travail de maman
il est temps grand temps de réparer nos
erreurs aidez nous à faire sortir de
l'ombre tous les supers nous devons
changer l'opinion des gens sur les
super-héros et pour cela élastique earl
est notre meilleur atout meilleur que
moi
j'adore le nom au travail de maman au
revoir chérie je m'occupe des enfants
pas de problème
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire pas
le prendre dit qu'on doit utiliser cette
méthode je connais pas cette méthode est
pourquoi ils changent les maths les
vagues scélérates
les massais démarre tout comme chili
comment les enfants revient gibert
c'est soit la plus de dolus tence et
jacquet est très en forme c'est quoi ça
ok tiens tiens voici bloqués waouh
d'accord ça c'est plus beau c'est
complètement fou mans pour aider ma
famille je dois la quitte t il pour
faire régner la loi la transgresser pour
nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent avoir
le choix
[Musique]
combustion imminente qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
dunod teaser en terro ce programme afin
de vanter ivoirien message en file pour
costume ça va chauffer j'arrive tu me
dépêche
[Musique]